so first you need to understand the
questions when they say express this as
a single trigonometric ratio it's
actually a pretty crappy way of giving
you a trig identity proof except they
just don't tell you what the edges all
they tell you is once you get something
at the end it's either go to sine X or
cot X or Tana to sell you like that it
will be one triggering expression but
when talking to you what is so that's a
bit sleep okay however I want you to
look at the questions what cleaners does
it give you that you should be able to
take as a don't just go through this
randomly actually take a particular part
to sign to simplify the objects that
you've got any suggestion some of you
got this question what did you do I used
to do okay t results is a good way to go
about any trig identity when you look at
it you're like I've got nothing I don't
really know where to go is completely
unclear and all I want to do is simplify
out so there's good reasons to go in
that direction however I pour you out
the form the disadvantage of T result is
two things number one you don't get all
the solutions when you're solving an
equation with T results which solution
do you miss hundred eighty degrees okay
is that a problem in this question a lot
why not because you are not solving an
equation right so that's good but
there's another problem that t results
introduces not so much a problem for the
disadvantage right when you did T
results you compared to working with you
result where the question I showed you
another way of doing you t resulted
universally longer it's a long way to go
about things right so in this case you
can go through T results did you get GM
again equal marks right here yes okay so
that's fine it works out however just
personally I'm not going to go to that
method straightaway there's something
else I see it's a little more obvious
that I think can give you another clue
you don't screw this yeah okay the
double a goes there right they should be
in good quit early because I actually
know what the double able results for
cosine are huh
and they have squares in them right
squares now that's a good sign that
that's the direction you're going
because what's the whole thing apply to
a square root okay so it's kind of like
ding-ding-ding here's the sign so
they're trying to guide you in a
particular direction okay so when I
start to break this up the couple's
appointees you feel about this you can
see this a factor of four of the top
should do something with that back up I
then take it out and guess what there's
a square root and four is a square
number so in fact I'm just going to go
straight to this like so right and then
this is a too hard for fun do you mean
no one put up links with it okay now
looking a look at this being the
conjugates right
not the kind of conjugating you used to
dealing with but it's a really good
signal to you all word is going to be
heaps of the candles out here right what
is the ability for close to it so
there's actually three if you remember
this is three and I want you to think
about which one's getting most useful to
you so let's just state which the three
offers what's the basic one one you love
the first time cosmos is really hot
because they are squared in there what
that shows you is oh wait I can convert
either v2 into the other right so by 10
bits into one minus sine squared X
because using the practical island onion
I can do that then the whole thing
becomes 1 minus 2 sine 3x alternatively
I can convert that into 1 minus cos
square there's a double negative for
that minus cos squared so will become
this okay
now I want you to look carefully at what
you've got here that you're only
substituting
you've got a 1 plus this on the top and
all of these choices which would be the
most offensive or choose how about this
one did you see why I'm going there good
look be able one plot here and then
you've got a minus one there it's just
going to clap out nicely for you
and remember you're kind of head toward
a single trig expression right we got
this guy which one you choose now this
is one minus so the feature here to
think about right but in other words I
want something in here which is a
positive one in there because if there's
a 1 here take away a positive one
there's the 1 again just like a
numerator cancels so which one is that
it's the second one right it's different
so I'm going to choose those this is the
thinking process you've got to go
through before you start to write down
because if you choose the wrong ones you
just end up going down a rat upon
particular very efficient path through
so I've got that two other problem I
have looked at my options I write them
down just like this because it's just
too much to hold in my brain right and
they'll see oh now I can see it it makes
a little more obvious what I should
shoot on the top I'm going to go one
plus two your cos squared minus one on
the bottom I'm going to have one I
choose again one minus one minus two
times where it kind of solves it
something here doesn't it yeah let me
just finish it up for you but there is
actually one little thing I should point
out you're one cancel which they do it
is your 1 careful again which leave you
with this watch after that double
negative
yeah those kids off ok what's happening
to you
so inside here consequent on things when
is the definition of cots squared right
now you see a square root and a square
and so attempting to just say ha it's
just quite well it's just quite in this
case you actually were given lead if you
said just quite X I'm pretty sure you
actually got marks for that but actually
you guys know a little better if you
think back to the first topic this year
it's not just connected it just big
we did it example on Monday if you just
take the square root of the number right
square root of the square root of
mushing thing you usually just get the
fired don't you maybe get the number you
startled you yeah but not always
what's this equals
well that's 25 and the square root of 25
is still 5 okay so in this case you
didn't get the number back what did you
get you got the absolute value of that
so this is where you should like okay
now put your pen down and think about
this for those of you who didn't get to
last this question where did it fall
down where did you come apart expanding
what did you do you expand that taken
what did you expand with okay so you
mean like it's years at time zero okay
so there are just arithmetic errors that
you can make I actually suggest as I go
through the area that I kind of made
when I started at questions like this
I thought less about the decisions I
made I just started to do things at
random the first thing I thought of
I would just like substituted okay now
you can vary sometimes
luckily luck out you know and get get an
intern at the end but you will if you do
you'll take twice as long to get there
and if you're doing it badly you won't
get to an ulcer you just sort of go in
circles and you if you don't take care
you'll end up like restarting so
wonderful I done okay so that make sense
please do this really carefully I can
extremely became